I saw you in wanderlust just a couple
days ago and you had me crying I was
laughing so hard in this movie you're
such a jerk thank you and I realize you
character played a role models also
incredibly obnoxious this seems to be a
talent of yours my wheelhouse I have a
little bit of a dick inside me
not illiterate not literally thank God
Betty White's not here I didn't I asked
her to leave you don't want to be around
for this guy now one of your jobs was to
get the other actors to do some pretty
intense and outrageous things there's
there's some full frontal male nudity
and a movie and I can't believe you
that's a bet the actor who does that is
a friend of yours I couldn't believe you
got him to do it old friend Joe lo
Truglio we were in a state together a
long time ago and thank you I was I was
going to add recognition applause later
again you've blown it but we asked Joe
to do the part where like it's a nudist
wine enthusiast novelist and and he's
like oh of course I'll do it and then
like a couple of minutes later he called
back and he's like but so I'm nude I
have to be nude the whole time and we
said yeah and so we talked about we all
thought it was probably best that he get
a prosthetic penis because you know when
you're shooting
if somebody's standing around just naked
just nude it's gonna be uncomfortable
for someone it's either gonna be
uncomfortable because the guys standing
around nude when he doesn't have to be
nude or and then everybody's just
uncomfortable like we understand why it
would be uncomfortable what do you mean
we get it well you know why perhaps
service table with open bowls in a dip
yeah
hummus
yeah okay I'm gonna move us on from that
image but but we so we got so we got him
too so it's a prosthetic yeah yeah that
goes over the real you know he goes over
said so it's a real authentic looking
penis over his real penis but for some
reason it was very liberating on onset
for all of us everybody felt much more
comfortable to be around him it's not
reach it's there but it's not realistic
it's rubber it but it so every what you
know people would like walk by you
couldn't do that with Joe's real penis
in college we all went through a phase I
suppose I'd be so awesome if after the
second day he stopped yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
[Applause]
somebody's there we were talking
backstage before the show I came in your
dressing room that you and your lovely
wife beautiful beautiful woman thank you
um I'd linger too long with her I know I
should I should I you should fight me
but but I went backstage and you had
talked about how you know you've been in
this business a while and that you
you've been in tons you've made guest
appearances and tongue a lot of shows
like forgettable guest appearances and
and some some worked on some shows that
people kind of recognize me from but
usually I'm approached by people who are
like hey are you I know you from
something like what do you how do I know
you right and then I have to say I don't
know what do I have to get I can't I'm
not gonna give you my resume it's just
right I don't know how you know me
exactly and then they finally like the
weirdest ones are like the like the guys
my age were like Dawson's Creek
you were Joey's professor on JA Dawson's
Creek and I'm like yeah is that you were
on Dawson's Creek I was on Dawson's
Creek yeah yeah that's whoa
well this is real so what what were what
was your role on Dawson's Creek I was
her litter and and actually the the I
still I don't remember anything but for
some reason I remember the first line of
that show that I did because it was
crazy ridiculous on how long it was and
it was about Judy Blume and I can like I
still remember it I think I'll probably
give you a really difficult line to say
about Judy Blume yeah so I just kind of
kept saying it over and over again for
the audition thinking oh well it's not
never gonna make it into the actual show
but for the audition I want to be able
to say it okay so I will say for you
right now if you say something negative
say something negative about Judy Blume
I really don't like Judy Blume books hey
don't knock Judy Blume without her my
younger self would never have been able
to decode the random acts of madness
perpetrated by that fascinating creature
known as the teenage girl
you